you
[Music]
in this topic we will learn about Amazon
glacier Amazon glacier is an economical
storage solution to store data that
would remain forever but rarely accessed
it is an ideal choice for data backup
and archiving provides data security of
the highest level and offers flexibility
in both storing and retrieving data AWS
builds you for only the used data or
storage and current lease price for
storing data in Amazon glacier is 0:07
cents per gigabyte per month maintaining
historical data can be a grief as it is
added to the administrative liability of
managing the scaling storage Amazon
glacier eases this hardship by providing
features such as capacity planning
hardware provisioning detecting and
repairing hardware failure data
replication and hardware migrations when
you preserve data in Amazon glacier it
is stored as archives this enables a
user to store a single file or a
combination of several files archives
are arranged in vaults which can be
accessed using the AWS I am service
Amazon glacier stores data in transit
via SSL and uses the 256 bit advanced
encryption system AWS enables
organizations to store data in a
location that is convenient for their
businesses and organizations tend to
utilize Amazon glacier to support the
following use cases archiving off-site
enterprise information backing up media
assets storing research and scientific
data preserving digital data and
replacing magnetic tapes the Amazon
glacier archives offers an average
annual resilience of 99.999999 99 9% the
archiving service maintains resilience
by continuously utilizing several
facilities and
within each facility to store the data
the task continues till the service
returns success on the uploading
archives any individual object archived
in to Amazon glacier such as a document
video or any other type of file is
referred to as an archive each archive
has a unique ID assigned to it by AWS
the archives are stored in vaults a
vault is addressed by a unique name
assigned to it by its creator a given
AWS account may create up to 1000 vaults
in Amazon glacier you can refer to an
archive in Amazon glacier via a URL that
points to the glacier service and
consists of the following three
components the account ID of your AWS
master account the name of the vault the
ID of the individual archive
data stored in Amazon glacier by Amazon
s3 cannot be retrieved using the Amazon
glacier API this is the data that Amazon
s3 manages on your behalf and it does
not show up as a vault or archive Amazon
s3 archived files can be restored using
the s3 management console interface or
using the Amazon s3 API files added
directly to Amazon glacier using the
Amazon glacier API can be retrieved
using the glacier API retrieval requests
can be any one of the following direct
retrieval of a single archived object by
archived ID filter by archive creation
date ranged archive retrieval retrieve
only a specific range of bytes from a
specific archive you can pull for job
completion using the described job API
function Amazon glacier completion
notifications can also be sent using
Amazon simple notification service or
SNS once an Amazon glacier job has
finished executing the user can request
a download of their thawed data
in this demonstration you'll learn how
to configure Amazon s3 buckets for
archiving in Amazon glacier which is a
lost cost storage service
you
first you need to go to s3 under the
storage and content delivery section
select your acquired bucket for this
demonstration we'll select the test 11
October bucket
click the lifecycle option click Add
rule
select the whole bucket option click the
configuration rule button
select the archive to the glacier
storage class option
state the number of days after the
completion of which you want the data in
your s3 bucket to move to the glacier
for this demonstration we'll provide 30
days as you can see in the example
provided the objects in s3 bucket will
move to glacier after the completion of
30 days
ignore
that you are aware that setting up this
particular rule will likely increase
your storage costs click review provide
a rule name you can review your rule on
this page
click create and activate rule as you
can see the rule has already been added
you have learned how to configure Amazon
s3 buckets for archiving in Amazon
glacier hey once you become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler channel and click here to watch
more such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here